bonjour à tous à suivre cet après-midi
et bien la suite des débats des
sénateurs sur le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2015 après avoir amendé et adopté les
trois premières parties du texte
consacré aux exercices 2013 et 2014 et
surtout aux recettes du budget 2015 et
bien les sénateurs examinent depuis hier
soir et bien les dépenses la quatrième
partie de ce budget de la sécurité
sociale
cet après midi les discussions
reprennent à l'article 51 article appelé
en priorité consacré un sujet très
important est assez polémique celui de
la transfusion sanguine en effet à la
suite d'une décision de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne
ce projet de loi prévoit que
l'établissement français du sang devra
conserver et distribue du plasma
thérapeutique fabriqués par des
fournisseurs étrangers fournisseurs
étrangers faisant appel à des donneurs
souvent rémunéré ce qui va complètement
à l'encontre de la législation française
agitation qui prévoit que le don de sang
doit rester bénévole et anonyme
il ya donc de nombreux amendements de
suppression qui ont été prévus par les
sénateurs tout de suite on prend donc la
direction d'hémicycle nous reprenons la
suite de la discussion du projet de loi
adopté par l'assemblée nationale de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2015 nous en revenons maintenant à
l'article 51 appelé en priorité monsieur
le président de la commission vous
m'avez demandé la parole oui merci
monsieur le président
a suite de la demande du gouvernement
donc nous allons examiner cet article 51
en priorité et j'avais donc demandé à ce
que l'on fasse une petite réunion de la
commission des affaires sociales dix
minutes avant la réunion c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on nous sommes un
peu en retard et nous vous adressons de
ce présent et à vous madame la miss nos
excuses on a essayé de trouver une
solution que nous n'avons pas
complètement trouvé la seule chose qu'on
a trouvé comme point commun c'est de
demander que vous appeliez en priorité
l'amendement 255 de manière à ce que
nous puissions ensuite engager la
discussion sur ce sujet merci monsieur
le président je suis donc saisi d'une
demande de priorités de la commission
des affaires sociales sur l'amendement
numéro 2 155 à l'article 51 afin qu'il
soit examiné avant les amendements de
suppression de cet article selon
l'article 44 alinéa 6 de notre règlement
la priorité est de droit quand elle est
demandée par la commission saisie au
fond sauf opposition du gouvernement
j'en suis amené madame la ministre à
vous demander quel est l'avis du
gouvernement sur cette demande de
priorité
madame le ministre oui je voulais
demander votre avis sur la demande de la
commission d'appel en priorité de
l'amendement numéro 200 familles je suis
ici pour
suivre les travaux tel que le souhaite
le sénat et donc je me plie bien
volontiers à la demande de la commission
j'en conclus que le gouvernement est
d'accord et donc la priorité est
ordonnée nous en venons donc à l'article
51 bien évidemment et comme il en a été
décidé à l'amendement numéro 255
noms sur deux vidéos
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre c'est vrai que cette priorité a
été demandé par la commission sur
l'article de l'amendement 255 mais il me
semble que si nous voulons que le débat
puisse avoir lieu sereinement les
quelques explications préalable s'impose
notamment concernant cet article 51 dans
sa globalité qui concerne le don du sang
puisque en effet le sang est une
ressource rare qui permet de soigner
plus d'un million de patients par an en
moyenne en france et ce grâce aux dons
de 1,7 million de donneurs le sang
humain permet donc de produire deux
catégories de produits à finalité
thérapeutique des produits sanguins
labiles et les médicaments dérivés du
sang le présent article vise donc à
donner au plasma thérapeutique le statut
de médicament ce qui ouvre nous
semble-t-il la voie à sa
commercialisation
or jusqu'à maintenant et en dépit d'une
directive européenne
la france continuer de considérer le
plasma thérapeutique comme un produits
sanguins labiles mais la france a été
condamnée par la cour de justice de
l'union européenne
et de fait par cet article reconnaît du
coup le statut de médicament au plasma
thérapeutique
ainsi pour nous la mise en oeuvre de
l'article 51 comporte trois principaux
risques un risque éthique d'abord un
risque sécuritaire
ensuite et surtout un risque
d'autosuffisance de plus cet article
prévoit que l'établissement français de
sang on servait distribuer ce plasma
d'origine non éthique ce qui est
contraire à ses missions
donc cette ouverture à la concurrence et
pour nous porteuse de fortes
conséquences pour l'établissement
français du sang qui devra donc se
réorganiser recentrer son activité sur
d'autres procédés et de même la collecte
de plasma bénévoles en france va
diminuer malgré un accroissement des
besoins nationaux et internationaux et
la présence territoriale de le fs centre
trouvera mise en cause pour toutes ces
raisons mes chers collègues nous avons
décidé de présenter cet amendement
puisque nous avons bien conscience que
nous ne pourrons pas
supprimer cet article 51 puisqu'il lait
résulte d'une décision de la cour
européenne donc nous nous devons de le
mettre en application
mais néanmoins par notre amendement nous
demandons à ce qu'un minimum d'éthique
soin apporté à la rédaction de cet
article
puisque nous sommes bien conscients donc
la france doivent se conformer d'abord
il nous semble que les associations de
donneurs de sang doivent être associés à
la réflexion menée par le gouvernement
et du coup
cela n'a pas été fait jusqu'à présent il
nous semble donc que l'éthique et la
maîtrise du risque doit guider le
gouvernement dans la dans la
transposition de la directive européenne
puisqu'il n'est pour nous pas concevable
que le ffs établissement français du
sang donne l'une des missions dans l'une
des missions pardon et de veiller au
strict respect des principes éthiques
par l'ensemble de la chaîne
transfusionnelle soient mis dans
l'obligation
notamment de conserver et distribuer un
produit non éthique puisque c'est là le
risque avec cet article 51 qui serait en
plus fabriqués par des laboratoires
étrangers nous connaissons en france les
conséquences dramatiques qui peuvent
résulter des errements en matière de
politique du sang nous avons donc créé
un l'établissement français du sang ou
le lfb laboratoire de fragmentation
pardon pour ne pas justement ont été
créés pour ne pas répéter les erreurs de
1993 alors il ne faudrait pas affaiblir
ces établissements tout ceci pour vous
dire qu'avec l'amendement que nous vous
proposons ici madame la ministre il
s'agit de rajouter dans cet article 51
donnons pas le supprimer mais de le
compléter par un alinéa qui permettrait
de faire entrer en vigueur en quelque
sorte une charte éthique charte éthique
je vous le rappelle qui a déjà été
adoptée lors d'un précédent texte le
texte dadu alors ces différentes
adaptations du droit de l'union
européenne qui concernait déjà des
mesures médicales cette charte a déjà
été adopté dans ce texte à l'initiative
d'olivier véran députés aient repris ici
par notre collègue jacky le menn donc il
serait nous semble-t-il tout à fait
gilles judicieux d'inclure cette charte
dans cet article 51 ce qui nous
permettrait aux uns et aux autres
d'adopter cet amendement ainsi modifié
voilà le sens de cet amendement monsieur
le président merci madame david quel est
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur général
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre nous avons à faire
effectivement un sujet extrêmement
complexe cet amendement résume la bvk la
position de beaucoup de sénateurs pour
pas dire de l'ensemble des sénateurs qui
sont attachés au respect du don gratuit
et il souligne que ceux ci ne règle pas
les problèmes de compatibilité avec
droit à la conquête de la concurrence
alors l'article 51 tirs les arts les
conséquences de l'arrêt de la cour de
justice européenne qui a considéré que
les plasma thérapeutique dans
l'élaboration dès qu'elle entre un
processus industriels sont des
médicaments
pour la cette question ça répond à un
certain nombre de remarques et qu'ils ne
peuvent donc relever du monopole de
l'établissement français du sang
en matière de produits sanguins labiles
notons d'abord que les produits sanguins
stables sont déjà des médicaments au
sens du droit et donc soumis à
autorisation de mise sur le marché et au
droit de la concurrence
donc l'article 51 tend à limiter les
effets de cette décision en prévoyant
qu'ils restent soumis bien sûr aux
règles de sécurité de l'hémato vigilant
ça répond aussi à une autre
interrogation
de nos collègues sénateurs je regrette
avec les auteurs des amendements de
suppression que les placements issus de
dons éthiques soient désormais soumis à
la concurrence de ceux qui ne sont pas
je note que si les clauses éthique ne
sont pas admises dans les contrats
rien
sauf parfois l'intérêt supérieur des
malades n'oblige les établissements
hospitaliers à acheter des places masse
préparer à partir de dos rémunérés
je rappelle que la rsm exerce un
contrôle renforcé sur les produits
sanguins qui relève de sa compétence
la traçabilité de chaque lot est assurée
par l' agence elle permet d'identifier
les prélèvements sanguins à partir
desquels a été fabriqué un lot donner de
médicaments les lots de médicaments
qui ont été fabriqués à partir de
prélèvements sont rien donné et les lots
dont proviennent les médicaments
administré à un patient les patients qui
ont reçu les médicaments c'est le don
qui a vraiment un suivi
par fait un de ce produit et de l' usage
de ce produit l'utilité de ce produit
enfin je tiens à insister sur le fait
que si cet article était supprimée cela
ne réglerait rien le juge national qui
applique la jurisprudence européenne se
contenterait de condamner la france à
payer des dommages aux entreprises qui
produisent le plasma et qui entre en
concurrence avec celui issu des dons
français nous n'aurions donc rien gagné
voilà
mesdames et messieurs mes chers
collègues ce que au nom de la commission
après avoir écouté les uns et les autres
et essayer de le creuser un peu la tête
sur les conséquences de ce qui apparaît
comme une
donnée de fonds
pour tous c'est à dire que
on entre ici en conflit avec l'éthique
qui est la nôtre et qui est partagé je
crois par tous c'est à dire du don
gratuit qui jusqu'à présent toujours été
la règle en france
madame la ministre quel est l'avis du
gouvernement
oui avant de donner mon avis je voudrais
revenir sur la situation à laquelle nous
répondons par cet amant par cet article
parce que
j'ai lors de la préparation des débats
rencontrer des parlementaires certains
sont dans cet hémicycle
rencontrer des interlocuteurs qui est je
le comprends fort bien ont exprimé des
inquiétudes
quant à la situation qui était créée
aujourd'hui et qui s'interrogeait sur
l'avenir du don éthique à la suite des
décisions sur lesquelles je vais revenir
qui ont été prises mais vous l'avez dit
monsieur le rapporteur général nous
sommes d'abord face à une situation
juridique
qui s'impose à nous
et je veux commencer par dire que
j'aborde cette situation juridique en
réaffirmant l'attachement de la france
aux conditions dans lesquelles le
prélèvement du sang est réalisé et donc
aux principes qui encadrent notre
système dont les trois piliers sont la
sécurité sanitaire que nous devons aux
receveurs et à quelques jours de
l'anniversaire du triste anniversaire
de la crise du sang contaminé nous
devons plus que jamais rappelé
l'attachement et l'engagement qui est le
nôtre à garantir cette sécurité
sanitaire le deuxième principe est celui
de l'autosuffisance et le troisième le
don éthique et ce sont ces principes qui
garantissent la qualité et la sécurité
des produits mis à la disposition des
professionnels de santé et des malades
ça c'est le cadre qui existaient et qui
continue d'exister ce sont des prêts
ainsi des valeurs des engagements qui
sont ceux de la france qui ne sont pas
partagées par tous les pays disons le
mais qui sont les nôtres
nous sommes aujourd'hui confrontés à une
double décision de justice
d'abord une décision de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne
et ensuite une décision du conseil
d'état
qui ont requalifier le plasma solvant
détergent qu'on appelle le plasma sd qui
jusqu'à aujourd'hui où jusqu'à ses
décisions étaient considérés comme sains
produits sanguins labiles c'est à dire
comme un produit qui pouvait être
produit et mis à disposition par
l'établissement français du sang au même
titre que d'autres types de plasma je
veux pas rentrer dans des détails les
médecins le savent très bien il ya trois
types de plasma qui existe et donc la
décision juridique ne porte que sur un
type de plasma le plasma dit sd et qui
jusqu'à maintenant étaient prélevés et
produit enfin il y avait prélèvement du
sang et production du plasma par
l'établissement français du sang et la
décision de justice européenne de la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
qui a été confirmée avec des
conséquences très concrètes sur
lesquelles je vais venir par le conseil
d'état a consisté à requalifier donc ce
plasma sd non plus comme un produits
sanguins labiles mais comme médicament
comme un médicament et donc cela crée un
contexte nouveau
cela va produire des changements qui
vont toucher en premier lieu des acteurs
institutionnels et notamment
l'établissement français du sang et je
comprends parfaitement les inquiétudes
qui naissent de cette décision parce que
nous devons évidemment dans le cadre de
cette évolution du droit faire en sorte
de ne pas désorganiser du jour au
lendemain la délivrance des produits
transfusionnelle des organisations qui
pourraient produire des difficultés le
conseil d'état dans sa dissidence ont
dans son arrêt à fixer une période de
transition qui va jusqu'au 1er février
2015 et donc à compter du 1er février
2015 qu'est ce qu'il veut à se passer
d'abord l'établissement français du sang
ne pourra plus produire de plasma sd
pour une raison simple qui est qu'il n'a
pas le statut d'établissement
pharmaceutique
l'établissement français du sang en
revanche garde le monopole de la
collecte du sang dans notre pays et il
continuera à proposer les deux autres
types de plasma qui n'ont pas le statut
de médicament le plasma inactivé dia et
le plasma sécurisé quarantaine dit est
ce donc concrètement à partir du 1er
février 2015 l'établissement français du
sang continue à avoir le monopole de la
collecte c'est lui qui fait des
prélèvements et il pourra produire deux
plasma sur trois et le plasma sd lui qui
est requalifiée en médicament ne peut
être produit que par des étés des
établissements pharmaceutiques
l'établissement français du sang n'ayant
pas ce statut d'établissement
pharmaceutique ne peut plus produire ce
plasma sd nous devons évidemment à
partir de là et c'est le deuxième
changement nous devons adapter le statut
juridique de ce plasma en permettant en
mettant en place un dispositif qui
permette d'assurer dès le 31 janvier
prochain dès le 1er février 2015 qui
nous permettent d'assurer un haut niveau
de sécurité pour les patients transfusés
et il est impératif de garantir un
système qui intègre en toute sécurité
des produits transfusionnelle de statut
juridique
différent et qui d'ailleurs feront
l'objet d'une vigilance différentes vous
l'avez vous même dit
puisque le mécanisme de vigilance n'est
pas le même selon que l'on parle d'un
médicament ou d'un autre produit qu'un
médicament le choix qui est fait
provisoirement et de maintenir le plasma
sd dans la filière des produits sanguins
labiles et d'assurer un double suivi de
ce plasma à la fois en pharmacovigilance
et en émaux vigilance pour des raisons
de sécurité de la chaîne
transfusionnelle de logique de
distribution de délivrance et de
conseils transfusionnelle
nous allons ensuite avoir à examiner des
demandes d'autorisation de mise sur le
marché et nous sommes d'ores et déjà
saisi d'autorisation de mise sur le
marché de produits s d de la part d'une
entreprise il y en aura sûrement
d'autres mais d'une entreprise dont je
vais pas dire 20 a
eu d'une entreprise mais qui est celle
qui avait introduit le recours devant le
conseil d'état donc et qui a gagné donc
cette entreprise va déposer une à mm je
tiens à dire que pour obtenir la mm il
sera inscrit noir sur blanc que dans les
documents dans l'appel dans les
documents que doivent être respectés les
principes du don éthique donc ça c'est
une exigence qui est posée je le dis
elle est posée dans les termes mêmes de
la pas comment on appelle ça la rfl de
documents dans le cahier des charges qui
sera proposé pour obtenir l'autorisation
de mise sur le marché donc je veux vous
rassurer sur ce point là vous rassurer
publiquement et solennellement
puisque je m'exprime devant la
représentation nationale le gouvernement
la laddh voc l'agencé nationale de
sécurité du médicament inscrira c'est
prévu c'est nous avons déjà commencé à
travailler là-dessus inscrits inscrire à
cette exigence de don éthique dans le
cahier des charges pouvons nous aller
j'en viens à votre amendement
jusqu'à
imposer par la loi le respect de cette
condition je souhaiterais pouvoir le
faire
la difficulté à laquelle je me heurte là
au moment de vous donner un avis ça
n'est pas mon hésitation sur le fond ça
n'est pas mon interrogation sur la
légitimité de votre demande c'est une
interrogation
juridique puisque une directive de
98 directive 2002 98 indique
explicitement que l'on peut promouvoir
le don éthique mais pas l'imposer et
donc la disposition serait contraire au
droit européen et ne pourrait pas être
sanctionné pas censuré par le conseil
constitutionnel qui n'est pas juge de la
compatibilité avec les textes européens
mais ferait l'objet d'une attaque le cas
échéant par un organisme quelconque donc
il me sens moi ce que je proposerai
volontiers parce que très sincèrement je
comprends à 300% s'il chose m'exprimer
ainsi votre démarche est elle rencontre
celle du gouvernement qui encore une
fois a à a prévu d'inscrire dans cahier
des charges cette exigence moi je me
demande si on peut pas travailler
peut-être dans les heures qui viennent
à
écrire
disons oui préposé un sous-amendement
qui ferait référence aux dispositions de
l'article de la santé
publique elle 51 21-11 et aux exigences
de la directive européenne c'est-à-dire
qui inscrit qui parlerait de deux
promotions en tous cas d'une rédaction
qui ne viendraient pas frontalement en
opposition avec la rédaction de la
directive parce que vaille à un moment
ou un autre ou juridiquement ça ne
passera pas voilà je vous le dis donc je
ne veux pas donner un avis défavorable
parce que je trouve ça extrêmement
compliqué donc le sous un vent n'ont
même pas quelques heures voilà le
sous-amendement on pourrait imaginer que
ce ce que après
aux médicaments dérivés du sang donc la
première phrase de votre amende de votre
amendement la première ligne par don de
votre amendement vous dites compléter
cet alinéa à part les mots à condition
de respecter le régime applicable aux
médicaments dérivés du sang mois après
je vous propose d'ajouter en obtenant
une autorisation de nuit sur le marché
qui respecte l'article l 51 21-11
du code de la santé publique et en
respectant les exigences prévues par la
directive 2002 tirait
98-76 le dire dans ce cas là que si
elles étaient confrontés à du sang non
éthiques là mêmes ne pourrait pas être
ne pourrait être délivrée qu'en
situation de rupture
d'approvisionnement et de d'urgence en
quelque sorte sur le marché voilà ce que
je propose pour entendre votre demande
merci madame la ministre donc si j'ai
bien compris vous proposer une nouvelle
rédaction de l'article 2 de l'article
250 de pardon de l'amendement
255 à l'article 51 dont nous ne
disposons pas encore dans sa formulation
définitive
ce qui m'amène à vous faire la
proposition suivante si vous en étiez
d'accord et là j'ai besoin de l'avis de
la commission est de l'avis du
gouvernement donc que nous dit fériau
l'examen de cet amendement est donc de
l'article 51 de manière à ce que tout le
monde puisse disposer de la version
je peux m'exprimer un homme briques
merci
afin que tout le monde puisse disposer
de la version définitive du sous
amendement proposé par le gouvernement
et que la discussion soit la plus claire
possible
la commission pourrait se réunir
peut-être avant la reprise de ce soir de
manière à ce que tout le monde et toutes
les données en main de façon à ce que
nous puissions trancher en toute
connaissance de cause
oui
avez vous un avis monsieur le rapporteur
cette proposition aux clients nous
continuons la discussion
le sous-amendement est en train
d'arriver monsieur
donc il faudrait peut-être nous
l'imprimer et puis bon je sais que
madame la ministre est passé mais je
voudrais quand même quelques minutes de
suspension afin que les membres de la
commission puisse à nouveau se réunir
afin d'en discuter parce que je peux pas
vendre la division à leur place le
le président vous avez besoin de combien
de temps à 5 minutes
combien 5 5 minutes madame cayeux
je voulais madame la ministre simple
simplement vérifier auprès de vous ce
que vous entendiez par sens éthique nous
nous avons une idée mais mes collègues
échanger avec moi en se demandant ce que
vous entendiez par son éthique nous
pourrions
alesi madame la ministre mais nous
pourrions reprendre cette discussion
lors de l'examen de la nouvelle version
si vous en êtes d'accord
nous pourrions reprendre cette
discussion est la réponse du
gouvernement à toutes les questions qui
se posent lors de l'examen
de la version définitive de l'amendement
1 nous procédons comme ça donc une
suspension de séance de 5 10 minutes 5
parfait la science est suspendu
un nouvelle version de cet amendement
est en train d'être de vous distribuez
de sous-amendements pardon est en train
de vous être distribuée de manière à ce
que chacun d'entre vous puisse en
prendre connaissance la commission
c'est réunit donc
monsieur le président que le rapporteur
général vous pouvez nous faire part des
réflexions voire des décisions devant la
commission des affaires sociales pas
faire de longs discours jeu
la commission qui vient se réunir a émis
un avis favorable sous amendements et
remercie effectivement à madame la
ministre d'avoir entendu
nos demandes est avoir fait cette
proposition qui je crois
remplies notamment une des conditions
qui nous paraissait essentiel c'est à
dire le don éthique de don gratuit du
sens donc pour toutes ces raisons nous
sommes favorables messieurs donc nous
pouvons considérer que nous reprenons la
discussion sur cette nouvelle version de
l'amendement madame la ministre vous
voulez vous exprimer ou vous considérez
que l'amendement a été suffisamment pour
le sous-amendement pardon était
suffisamment france donne un avis
favorable à l'amendement
sous-amendé par le sous amendement qui a
été présentée je profite de cette prise
de parole pour répondre à madame la
sénatrice cayeux lui dire que le don
éthique c'est un don qui est
gratuit anonyme bénévole et
non rémunérés gratuit voilà c'est ça
sert que il ya des pays dans lesquels on
rémunère d'autres dans lesquels on
indemnise et voilà et
et dans laquelle l'anonymat n'est pas
garanti donc c'est l'ensemble de ces
conditions qui constituent le système
français qui est assez particulier
merci madame la ministre donc nous
allons passer aux explications de vote
madame génisson on m'avait demandé la
parole
merci monsieur le président je remercie
nos collègues du groupe crc qui nous ont
aidés à grandir à pouvoir voter cet
article 51 et ainsi que madame la
ministre qui nous permet de
respecter un sujet qui nous semble tout
à fait fondamentale qui est le sujet du
don éthique madame la ministre vous nous
avez indiqué que l'établissement
français du sang auraient interdiction
de produire le plasma sd à partir du 31
janvier 2015 dès lors qu'il n'était pas
établissements pharmaceutiques donc la
première des questions que je souhaitais
vous poser c'est savoir s'il était
possible que l'établissement français du
sang acquiert cette compétence
d'établissement pharmaceutique dans
quelles conditions cela pouvait se
passer et si l'établissement lui-même
était comment dire
candidat à 7 à cette activité
le deuxième sujet c'est 6 pouces si vous
pouviez nous a formés déjà sur le fait
que
des labos étrangers
et solliciter l'autorisation de mise sur
le marché car bien évidemment nous
sommes tous attachés les uns les autres
au fait qu'il faut pas qu'il y ait de
rupture de soins pour nos concitoyens et
en sachant que l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché prend quand même un
certain temps et dès lors est ce que ces
labos étrangers auront en dans la tente
de la dès l'autorisation de mise sur le
marché une demande d'autorisation
temporaire du talent ils utilisent
d'utilisation pardon en rappelant quand
même et ça c'est pour la petite histoire
c'est que la condamnation de la france
par la cour européenne de justice est
due à au laboratoire qui va être le
premier candidat pour nous comment dire
nous fournir ce fameux plasma sd là
l'autre question que je souhaitais vous
poser c'est celle concernant
l'établissement français du sang parce
que cette production de ce plasma est
quand même une production importante je
pense que ça représente à peu près 20 25
% de l'activité de l'établissement
français du sang donc ça va entraîner
une restructuration très importantes
alors même qu'on connaît par ailleurs la
qualité de à la fois au niveau enfin
dans ses différentes compétences que ce
soit la collecte que ce soit le sujet de
la fabrication le sujet de la délivrance
la qualité de l'établissement français
du sang et puis enfin sur sur le don
éthique merci d'avoir proposé votre le
sous-amendement que que nous allons que
nous allons adopter parce que au-delà de
l'aspect j'allais dire éthiques le fait
que ce soit un don gratuit anonyme et
bénévoles au-delà de l'aspect éthique
c'est aussi un sujet de santé publique
parce que l'on sait que plus on
diversifie
comment dire l'origine du don et puis il
y a deux partenaires dans le dos plus on
a le risque de multiplier des problèmes
je vais vous citer un exemple notre
collègue le roscouet n'ai voté évoqué
hier le sujet
et comment des problèmes infectieux en
milieu carcéral en particulier sur le
vih et sur l'hépatite c est quand
malheureusement le drame du sang en
particulier avec la contamination vih a
éclaté je rappelle que les centres de
transfusion du nord et du pas de calais
ont été beaucoup moins touchés que les
autres centres de transfusion de france
parce qu'ils avaient interdit le
prélèvement en milieu carcéral ça pour
dire que pu en étant le panel de
donneurs
que ce qu'on soit dans un don gratuit
anonyme ou non plus le risque les
risques en matière de santé publique
existe donc je pense qu'il faudrait
effectivement dans la déclinaison de ce2
sous-amendement être très très stricte
pour faire respecter le don éthique
gratuit et bénévole c'est à dire le don
éthique en ayant peut-être aussi un
débat qu'on pourrait ça serait le c'est
l'honneur de la france de promouvoir ce
don éthique et je crois que ce pourrait
être aussi un
sujet que la france pourrait porter au
niveau européen mais je suis persuadé
madame la ministre que c'est déjà ce que
vous faites merci madame génisson la
parole était monsieur gilles
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre de remarque aussi à mon tour
sans être être énorme puisque nous
sommes nombreux à intervenir
première remarque ou première question
est ce que dans le cadre de ce
sous-amendement et est ce qu'il y a de
votre part une possibilité de bien nous
confirmer que nous ne sommes pas ici
dans une remise en cause totale des
principes affirmés réaffirmée
régulièrement depuis la loi 93 5 du 4
janvier 93 relatives à la sécurité en
matière de transfusion sanguine et de
médicaments voter bien sûr à la suite du
scandale du sang contaminé
et deuxième remarque
il faut rappeler que à la fois
l'organisation mondiale de la santé le
conseil de l'europe
la fédération internationale de la
croix-rouge et le croissant-rouge prône
la généralisation
système actuel à la française chloé metz
et il ya en même dit
de se fixer comme objectif d'atteindre
100 % de dons volontaires et non
rémunérés y compris pour les médicaments
dérivés du plasma en 2020 donc alors que
toutes ces organisations et pas des
moindres ont loué le système entre dieux
mais à la française est-ce qu'on peut
tenir compte de leurs recommandations ou
est-ce que tout est remis à plat par cet
article le fait bien évidemment qui
feuilles se mettre en conformité
juridique nous le comprenons bien
évidemment merci monsieur gilles la
parole était la présidente debré
vous avez eu la réponse monsieur
delattre alors c'est à vous
un ministre sur le fond nous en
remettons à la sagesse des commissaires
de la commission mais d'un point de vue
de l'organisation de la loi dans ce pays
ces mesures sont totalement églement
terre donc totalement et long terme
la lutte était préférable de dire
aux auteurs de l'amendement mon parent
mesures réglementaires je prendrai les
mesures de normes de qualité et sécurité
pour la collecte le contrôle ans qu'en
réalité même si les directives
européennes était reine dans le maine
législatif comme dans le domaine
réglementaire donc c'est totalement un
commentaire il ya ma connaissance
l'article 34 et 37 n'ont pas encore été
supprimées si on se dit alors on nous
accuse toujours de nous mêler un peu de
trop à vouloir détailler dans la loi je
crois qu'on en ait beaucoup sur
l'efficacité alors je crois qu'il aurait
été préférable à la musque vous prenez
simplement un engagement plutôt qu'un un
amendement un sous-amendement
pour laquelle les noms demande de la
très compétente commission de la sphère
sociale ont quand même un peu de mal à
s'y retrouver quoi voilà donc pour
toutes ces raisons nous voterons sur la
confiance le conseil des membres de la
commission mais d'un point de vue
franchement législatif et nous sommes
dans l'assemblée la deuxième assemblée
nous voulons tous sauver le bicamérisme
la moindre des choses serait de gérer
correctement
monsieur delattre la parole est à
monsieur roche
puis sur ce dossier nous avions quatre
préoccupations principales la première
était bien sûr la permanence du souhait
on peut toujours être en rupture de
stock c'était important la deuxième
chose c'est un problème un souci de
pharmacovigilance bien sûr la troisième
était un problème juridique par rapport
à la juridiction européenne est en fait
nous avions un problème d'éthique je
pense qu'après les productions qui a été
fait par notre collègue david la réponse
très précise la ministre et l'a prouvé
la proposition qui a été faite de deux
de réduire très d'actions conduites tout
à fait quand sensuelle bien sûr nous
allons au seul nom du groupe u10 nous
allons voter ce texte est bien sûr notre
ma demande nous avions proposé sur ce
chapitre tombe merci monsieur roche
monsieur savary vous avez la parole
je souscris ce qui a été proposé
simplement j'ai bien écouté vos propos
et je voudrais avoir quelques précisions
puisque vous avez dit que
l'établissement français du sang
pourrait continuer à collecter mais
pourrait plus produire ce sens sd du
fait qu'il n'avait pas
n'était pas établissements
pharmaceutiques
est ce qu'une des solutions pour
revaloriser également l'établissement
français du sang et le mettre à égalité
par rapport aux laboratoires industriels
ne serait pas de deux adossé à ses
compétences le statut d'établissement
pharmaceutique
eh ben j'ai la même question
fait qu'on aura la même réponse
merci monsieur savary
je n'ai plus de demandes de parole il y
en aurait-il d'autres madame la ministre
bien sûr
oui monsieur le président je vais
répondre aux quelques questions qui ont
été posées d'abord pour rassurer
monsieur j nous ne modifions pas le
cadre législatif général dans lequel
s'inscrit la collecte du sang les
pratiques de transfusion va tout tout
tout ce qui est lié à la sécurité
sanitaire rien ne change nous n'avons
qu'à tirer et l'article 51 et limité
dans son objet il s'agit de tirer les
conséquences d'un arrêt de la cour de
justice européenne sur cette question du
plasma
sd qui a un statut de médicament
désormais et s'il oms considère que le
système français est un exemple à suivre
c'est une recommandation qu'elle fait
nous ne pouvons pas faire beaucoup plus
que de d'encourager nos voisins à suivre
cette recommandation mais nous non
seulement nous la suivons mais c'est
nous qui l'avons en quelque sorte
suscité donc nous sommes plus qu'un
accord avec l'organisation mondiale de
la santé c'est vrai que ce sont des
dispositions réglementaires monsieur le
sénateur et c'est pour cela d'ailleurs
de type réglementaire et c'est pour cela
que l'article initial ne le prévoyait
pas je ne peux néanmoins
rester insensible aux préoccupations
très fortes qui ont été exprimées tant
le sujet est complexe à la fois dans les
deux assemblées et à l'extérieur par un
certain nombre d'associations en
particulier les associations de donneurs
est donc en tout cas ce que je souhaite
c'est que le débat extrêmement
intéressant qui a lieu ici serve de
caisse de résonance pour rassurer à la
fois les donneurs les receveurs et nos
concitoyens sur la question du statut de
la ffs c'est évidemment une question de
bon sens mais l'établissement français
du sang est très loin d'avoir les
caractéristiques lui permettant d'être
considéré comme un établissement
pharmaceutique
ce qui ne veut pas dire que la
transition ne pourrait pas se faire mais
elle prendrait un temps certain en tout
cas beaucoup plus long que la période à
laquelle de transition à laquelle nouvel
appareil à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés
elle appellerait
d d'ailleurs la mise en place de
procédures différentes de recrutement de
pharmaciens des engagements même des
aménagements matériels donc la question
ne peut pas être écartée je le dis même
si l'établissement français du sang lui
même ne semblait pas considéré comme
facile pour lui de s'engager dans cette
direction néanmoins c'est une réflexion
qui doit avoir lieu mais si elle la
décision devait être prise aller dans ce
sens là encore une fois nous
n'aboutirons pas avant une période assez
longue voilà
merci madame la ministre
s'il n'y a plus de prise de parole je
vais donc mettre aux voix le
sous-amendement 329 rectifiée présentée
par le gouvernement avec l'avis
favorable de la commission qui est pour
ce sous-amendement
qui contre qui s'abstient le
sous-amendement est donc adopté jeu mais
maintenant aux voix l'amendement
255 ainsi sous-amendé par l'amendement
le sous-amendement 329 rectifier
j'imagine que c'est le même vote vous me
confirmer le même vote donc l'amendement
255 ainsi sous amendé et adopté en
conséquence les huit amendements du 21
rectifié terre aux 254 tombe et nous en
arrivons à l'article euh pardon à
l'article à l'amendement 146 rectifiée
présentée par monsieur roch
on sait pas une présentation de
demain c'est pur jus saisi par la france
aux deux sénateurs françois zocchetto
nos chefs du groupe qui voudrait faire
une rectification de vote pour hier pour
les amendements 9 rectifié bis 84
rectifié 197 rectifier et 234 et 234
entend supprimer l'article 14 du projet
de loi c'est monsieur roche à tes
données de votre mise au point sera
publié au journal officiel et figurera
dans l'analyse politique du scrutin donc
nous en revenons à l'article 146 à la
demant 146 rectifié qui le présente
monsieur barbier
nous en sommes à damas à l'amendement
146 rectifier à l'article 51
il est retiré parfait donc nous passons
à l'amendement 147 rectifier monsieur
barbier
qui concerne la suppression des alinéas
14 et 15 de l'article 51
il est retiré nous en arrivons donc à
l'amendement 133 rectifié monsieur
gilles
il est retiré
un amendement numéro 65 e présenté par
le rapporteur général au nom de la
commission monde mon rédac sur l'île et
rédactionnelles pas d'opposition
favorables donc il est adopté
et l'arctique et d'abonnements 255 bien
nous l'avons traité donc eh bien je vais
mettre aux voix l'article 51 ainsi
amendée qui est pour l'article 51 ainsi
amendée qui et contre qui s'abstient
l'article 50 et ainsi amendé est adopté
nous reprenons le cours normal de notre
discussion avec eux l'article 44 bis sur
lequel aucun amendement n'a été déposée
je le mets aux voix qui est pour
l'article 44 bis qui et contre qui
s'abstient l'article 44 bis est adopté
nous en arrivons à l'article 45 avec un
amendement 159 présentée par monsieur
qu'a dit que vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président madame
ministre chers collègues l'article 39 de
la loi de finances de sécurité sociale
pour 2014 a donné la possibilité aux
établissements de santé de mettre en
place une expérimentation de je cite
nouvelles modalités d'organisation de
régulation des transports pour une
période n'excédant pas trois ans les
établissements dans lesquels des
économies seront constatés pour en
recevoir une dotation d'intéressement
l'objectif de cet article est de
proposer aux patients le mode de
transport le moins onéreux compatible
avec son état de santé élargir
l'expérimentation voitures de transport
avec chauffeur vtc permettrait aux
établissements volontaires de conclure
une convention avec les organismes
locaux d'assurance maladie et l' agence
régionale ouverte à sept autres
catégories de véhicules de transport de
personnes
l'objectif poursuivi est la réduction
des dépenses pour la sécurité sociale
par l'accroissement de la concurrence et
la stimulation de l'offre de service
lors d'une audition devant la mission
d'évaluation et de contrôle des lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale en
mai 14 en mai 2014 le directeur général
de la caisse nationale d'assurance
maladie des travailleurs salariés a
rappelé que de 2,3 milliards d'euros en
2003 les dépenses liées au transport de
patients sont passés à 4 milliards
d'euros en 2013 leur place au sein de
des dépenses de l'assurance maladie
s'est donc accrue dans un contexte de
forte maîtrise de l'objectif national
des dépenses d'assurance maladie cette
croissance varie fortement selon le mode
de transport utilisé la dépense est
stable pour les véhicules sanitaires
légers elle s'élève à 800 millions
d'euros depuis dix ans elle a augmenté
de 700 millions d'euros pour les aides
aux ambulances passant de 900 millions
d'euros en 2003 à 1,6 milliard d'euros
en 2013 tout en demeurant à peu près
stable depuis 2010 en revanche les
dépenses de taxi ont triplé passant de
500 millions d'euros en 2003 à 1,5
milliard d'euros en 2013 soucieux de
limiter notre dépense publique il paraît
opportun de permettre aux patients
d'opter pour une voiture de transport et
chauffeurs si cela permet de faire
baisser les coûts 6
merci monsieur k dick quel est l'avis de
la commission
monsieur le président
il ne nous paraît pas opportun d'étendre
ses expérimentations à un nouveau mode
de transport même si j'entends bien les
arguments qui sont développés par
monsieur k dick alors que l'objet du
présent article est précisément de
réguler l'offre de transports sanitaires
pour tenir compte de cette
croissance un peu exponentielle que la
cour des comptes d'ailleurs à juste iman
a justement
signalé surtout le dispositif proposé ne
paraît pas réunir toutes les garanties
de sécurité dans la mesure où il ne
prévoit pas les modalités de
conventionnement initiale des
entreprises de vtc avec l'assurance
maladie comme l'article 322 5 du code de
sécurité sociale le fait pour les taxis
donc pour toutes ces raisons
nous vous demandons le retrait ce
qu'indique
merci avait du gouvernement il pour les
mêmes raisons sinon avis défavorable
mais je cadic vous êtes sollicités pour
savoir si vous retirer votre amendement
je vous remercie j'ai très encouragée
mais j'ai écouté vos commentaires et je
pense que je vis convient peut-être
d'en prendre acte je pense
qu'effectivement ça ouvre le débat je
pense que la réflexion va s'installer
tôt ou tard on devra se poser cette
question est en tout cas je vous
remercie de m'avoir écouté je retire mon
amendement si monsieur k dick
la mode monsieur de c'est ça la 959 et
en retirer je mets aux voix l'article 45
qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient l'article
45 est adopté nous en arrivons à
l'article un article additionnel après
l'article 45 qui fait l'objet d'un
amendement 59 présentée par monsieur le
rapporteur général vous avez la parole
alors ce le président madame la ministre
il s'agit donc d'un article additionnel
après l'article 5 qui
a pour objet
celui ci les liaisons ville hôpital ont
un impact direct sur les prises en
charge et sur les coûts pour l'assurance
maladie il est urgent de prendre des
mesures afin d'organiser ses relations
d'une manière qui permette d'éviter les
soins inutiles nous l'avons déjà signalé
à maintes reprises et les ré
hospitalisations le gouvernement propose
à l'article 24 du projet de loi relatifs
à la santé une mesure qui paraît utile
et qui semble trop importante pour
attendre que ce texte soit adopté au
plus tôt au premier semestre 2015 votre
commission souhaite qu'elle puisse être
mise en oeuvre dès le 1er janvier
prochain
merci monsieur le rapporteur général à
vis du gouvernement
je donne un avis plutôt défavorable
monsieur le président parce que c'est un
élément qui fait partie de la loi de
santé qui s'inscrit dans une
réorganisation
des pratiques hospitalières du lien
entre l'hôpital et la médecine de ville
qui suppose un accompagnement une
concertation entre les différents
acteurs pour la mise en place de cette
formule et nous sommes dans la dernière
ligne droite de la fin la dernière ligne
droite je n'en sais rien mais la
dernière ligne en tout cas de la
concertation sur la loi de santé et
certains y compris parmi les
professionnels de santé les hospitaliers
sont très attachés à ce que cette
concertation puisse avoir lieu puis se
dérouler puis se faire même de manière
tout à fait formaliser et donc cette
mesure qui n'a pas de caractère sur les
finances d'ailleurs de la sécurité
sociale et qui donc ne trouve pas sa
place de façon naturelle dans le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale me semble pouvoir attendre la
loi de santé puisqu'elle représente une
pièce d'un ensemble plus large qui
trouve sa cohérence à voir l'ensemble
des pièces rassemblées donc j'ai plutôt
un avis défavorable sur le fait que le
texte que la mesure soit dans ce texte
là puisque sur le fond c'est une mesure
qui a été d'ores et déjà annoncés merci
madame la ministre je ne vois pas
d'explications de vote je vais donc
mettre aux voix cet amendement 59 qui
est pour avec un avis défavorable du
gouvernement
qui est contraint
là je vais être obligé de procéder à un
assis debout
car le résultat est incertain alors
qu'ils aient pour l'amendement 59
je
16 qui est contre
non il est pas de plus il n'est pas
adopté donc nous en arrivons
pardon au nom oui il est adopté excusez
moi mais
il est adopté
je vois que vous êtes attentif
nous en arrivons donc au chapitre 5
paiement des produits de santé à leur
juste prix
avec l'article 46 il ne fait l'objet
d'aucun abonnement je le mets aux voix
qui est peu et pour cet article 46
g contre qui s'abstient il est adopté je
ne crois pas m'être trompé cette fois
après l'article 46 un article
additionnel
avec un amendement
286 monsieur desessard j'imagine
vous pensez bien monsieur le président
donc c'est un amendement qui souhaitent
intégrer des parlementaires au comité
économique des produits de santé
le comité économique des productions
télé ces eps prend des arbitrages de la
plus haute importance concernant les
niveaux de financement solidaire des
spécialités pharmaceutiques et des
dispositifs médicaux cet amendement vise
donc à renforcer le contrôle
démocratique des travaux du crps en
intégrant des parlementaires d'une part
et le contrôle technique sur les travaux
des analyses menées et les conséquences
ultérieures sur les établissements de
santé grâce à une participation des
fédérations hospitalières représentative
d'autre part
en effet le conseil d'administration de
la rsm a été ouvert aux parlementaires
pour plus de transparence dans la même
logique il conviendrait d'appliquer
cette règle au conseil d'administration
du crps cet amendement reprend une
formulation une proposition formulée par
catherine lemorton dans son rapport sur
la prescription la consommation et la
fiscalité des médicaments rendue en
avril 2008 en conclusion des travaux de
la mission d'évaluation et de contrôle
des lois de financement
de la sécurité sociale cet article
trouve sa place dans le plfss puisqu'il
modifie la gouvernance d'un organisme
ayant un impact direct sur les finances
sociales c'est pourquoi madame
archambault et les sénatrices et
sénateurs écologistes ou demande de
l'adopter
merci monsieur de saissac et l'avis de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
général
on demande 286 oui oui
donc là
je parle au nom de la commission qui
n'est pas favorable à cette présence des
parlementaires dans l'instance chargée
de la négociation des prix et produits
de santé ça ne paraît pas adapté c2c
sarraut mission de l'instance et surtout
aussi à la fonction des élus
je pensais nous pensons tous que vous
demandez comme nous le faisons plus de
transparence sur la manière dont
fonctionne le cebs et je pense que nous
pouvons l'obtenir en usant des pouvoirs
actuels du parlement et notamment de
l'amex rcs que nous prévoyons avec
monsieur le président c'est une mission
pour
notamment levé un peu cette opacité
cette difficulté que nous avons à
comprendre le fonctionnement depuis la
mise sur le marché jusqu'à la fixation
du prix et à son évalue la suppression
contrôle
du médicament donc ce que nous vous
demandons c'est le retrait
merci quelle est la vie dans le rap
quel est l'avis du gouvernement
avis défavorable à cet amendement mais
se désistant je le dis très simplement
votre amendement ne parle pas de conseil
d'administration vous avez évoqué un
conseil d'administration en vous
exprimant il n'ya pas de conseil
d'administration du cep scps réunit une
à deux fois par semaine le cep est
cependant de longues heures le cep s est
placée auprès des ministres compétents
il est dense et un ans est un organe ou
un organisme très opérationnelle de
négociation des prix de renégociation de
suivi des médicaments
c'est une structure qui dépend du
pouvoir exécutif et à côté de cela il
est légitime évidemment que le parlement
encadre et contrôle l'activité du cps le
parlement définit les règles de fixation
des prix le parlement vote sur les
mesures de maîtrise des dépenses des
produits de santé remboursables c'est ce
que nous faisons dans chaque plfss le
parlement reçoit chaque année un rapport
d'activité du cep s est il a la
possibilité d'auditionner
le président
honnêtement je ne vois pas bien
comment nous pourrions avoir même en
termes de logique de qui fait quoi il me
semble qu'il ya là un mélange des genres
qui n'est pas qui n'est plus que fac est
totalement inopportun donc avis
totalement défavorable monsieur de ses
stars vous êtes sollicité pour un
retrait vous le maintenez
je le mets donc au revoir je ne vois pas
d'explications de vote
qui est pour cet amendement
286 avec un double avis défavorable
qui et contre
qui s'abstient l'amendement n'est pas
adopté nous en arrivons à l'article 47
avec un amendement 60 présentée par
monsieur le rapporteur général au nom de
la commission
rédactionnelles le président fait pas
d'opposition
avis favorable il est donc adoptée nous
passons à une série d'articles le oui
pardon l'article 47 il faut que je vais
soumettre aux voix qui est pour
l'adoption de l'article 47 qui est
contre
l'article 47 est adopté nous en arrivons
à une série d'articles additionnel après
l'article 47 avec un amendement 61
présentée par monsieur le rapporteur
général
alors cet amendement
propose dans un contexte de retour de
l'innovation en matière de médicaments
d'adapter les modes d'évaluation de
l'intérêt que représentent les nouvelles
substances dans ce cadre notre
commission vous propose de prévoir la
mise en oeuvre au 1er janvier 2016 d'une
réforme portée par la haute autorité de
santé qui permettra une comparaison plus
rigoureuse des médicaments et donc une
meilleure évaluation de l'intérêt de
leurs remboursements et donc de leur
prix cette réforme est proposé depuis
plusieurs années par la has haute
autorité de santé et des temps me
semble-t-il nous semble-t-il plus
exactement que les négociations avec les
industriels s'engagent c'est pourquoi
nous avons décidé de donner 1 heure
avant de donner oui plutôt dap de
d'avancer d'un an plus exactement
l'application de l'article
merci monsieur n'aura pas en général
quel est l'avis du gouvernement
je donne un avis défavorable mais je
voudrais expliquer pourquoi parce que
la question du mode d'évaluation des
produits de santé est évidemment une
question importante est à l'évidence
nous touchons les limites du système
actuel donc
c'est ce qui explique qu' il y ait un
regain d'intérêt ou d'attention sur ce
nouveau mode d'évaluation dit intérêt
thérapeutique
relatif pour la
décision d'admission au remboursement
des produits de santé
littéraire est un outil qui a été
développé par la haute autorité de santé
pour remplacer deux évaluations qui sont
le smr et la smr attribués aux
médicaments et on dit que parfois et
c'est ce que voulait s'y entendre
monsieur le rapporteur général que la
solution serait prête pour l'emploi mais
aujourd'hui il y à un consensus y
compris à la haute autorité de santé
d'ailleurs qui se développe pour
considérer que le système n'est pas
adapté il n'est pas adapté d'abord parce
qu'il ne s'applique pas à tous les
produits de santé il ne s'applique en
particulier pas aux dispositifs médicaux
et il ne paraît pas opportun de changer
de mode d'évaluation pour une partie
seulement des produits de santé en
disant on continue à avoir on a un
nouveau système pour les médicaments et
on garde autre chose pour les
dispositifs médicaux par ailleurs
littéraire ne permet lui de fixer un
taux de remboursement ni de prendre en
compte l'évaluation médico économique et
ses problèmes explique que la phase de
test qui a été menée par la haute
autorité de santé monsieur le rapporteur
général a été jugé par la haute autorité
elle même non conclusives nous sommes
toutefois convaincu de la nécessité de
repenser nos critères d'admission au
remboursement des produits de santé
c'est pourquoi un rapport complémentaire
a été commandé à l'inspection générale
des affaires sociales
la remise de ce rapport est prévue pour
la fin de l'année et à cette date je
demanderai à toutes les institutions
publiques compétentes sur le médicament
c'est à dire à la haute autorité de
santé à l'agencé nationale de sécurité
du médicament au cep ce dont nous venons
de parler à l'assurance maladie de faire
des propositions concrètes pour rénover
les critères d'évaluation des produits
de santé une concertation approfondie
doit par ailleurs avoir lieu avec
l'ensemble des acteurs et elle sera
menée avec les représentants de
l'industrie pharmaceutique qui est
concerné au premier chef par cette
évolution et nous devons à nouveau
mettre en place une phase de test parce
qu'on peut pas se permettre d'avoir une
évaluation qui soit pas assurée en la
matière les premières modifications
législatives qui pourraient être retirés
seraient alors inséré dans le projet de
loi relative à la santé y compris
éventuellement dans une phase 1 dépend
de la date à laquelle arrive ce texte
mais nous pouvons imaginer que ça se
fasse au sénat ou à l'assemblée en
fonction du parcours du texte je veux
dire que sur un sujet aussi important
qui entraînera des changements profonds
nous devons être certains des mesures
que nous proposons est aujourd'hui
compte tenu des évaluations qui ont été
menées il ne nous semble pas possible de
considérer indépendamment de la date
monsieur le rapporteur général que
l'index thérapeutique relatif pourrait
être mise en oeuvre on ne parle pas
simplement de 2016 de 2015 pour
anticiper 2016 mais aujourd'hui nous en
sommes arrivés à l'idée que même en 2016
cette orientation là n'est pas celle qui
doit être suivi donc je vous demanderais
au bénéfice de ses explications de bien
vouloir retirer votre amendement et je
m'adresse aussi à ceux qui sont porteurs
d'amendements qui vont dans le même sens
ultérieurement mais pour dire que la
réflexion n'est pas écartée qu'elle est
même accéléré approfondie et j'ai envie
de dire malheureusement parce que nous
placions beaucoup d'espoir dans cet item
malheureusement les tests qui ont été
menées nous permettent ne nous
permettent pas de franchir l'obstacle si
j'ose dire qui est devant nous
merci madame la ministre monsieur
l'entente en général
madame la ministre je voudrais bien vous
être agréable j'entends bien et je
comprends parfaitement les arguments ce
que nous avons reçu en retour de
l'audition que
qui nous a accordé du président de la
has exactement un avis contraire il nous
a dit que c'était un amendement
excellent qui concourait tout à fait aux
objectifs qui étaient les leurs et qu'il
souhaitait effectivement pouvoir mettre
en oeuvre rapidement
cet intérêt
thérapeutique relatif c'est à dire qui
introduit la notion comparaison
parlera pour évaluer l'intérêt du
médicament
je crois que les questions que nous nous
posons
sur justement le medic en trouve là pour
moi déjà une première application et
donc ne semble pas au vu de ce que nous
avons entendu de la part de la chasse
qui failli retardé donc yann en tout et
que pour nous une contradiction si vous
voulez je ne mets pas en cause ce que
vous dites mais jeudi on n'a pas entendu
la même chose de la part de la haute
autorité donc pour le moment moi je me
sors au nom de la commission tenue de
maintenir bien merci monsieur le
rapporteur général cet amendement est
maintenu monsieur daudigny m'a demandé
la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre chaque collecte j'avais
présenté le même amendement il y a un an
dans le cas du plfss donc pour 2014 le
moment n'avait pas été examinée faute
d'aller fin de l'examen du plfss les
arguments présentés par mon ami ministre
aujourd'hui me paraissent très solide et
convaincant dont je me situerais en
retrait par rapport à cet amendement
dans le cas de la discussion aujourd'hui
à billets
oui monsieur le président moi je
fectivement on est on est tous
intéressés par les allées le plus
rapidement possible vers une remise en
forme de ce problème du médicament et de
la manière dont il est mis sur le marché
effectivement pour avoir un peu regardé
plus près on est actuellement quand même
un petit peu dans le flou alors
peut-être que le la haute autorité de
santé souhaiterais qu'on légifère dans
ce domaine mais très honnêtement moi je
vais au moins m'abstenir parce que j'ai
encore pas tout compris comment ça se
passe
merci monsieur barbier je ne vois plus
d'autres explications de vote donc je
vais mettre aux voix cet amendement 61
avec un avis défavorable du gouvernement
qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté
l'amendement est adopté nous passons à
l'amendement 292 monsieur de ses stars
déjà en 2008 la mission d'évaluation et
de contrôle des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale
soulignait que le système d'admission
remboursement des médicaments fondée sur
l'appréciation du smr service médical
rendu est peu sélectif la quasi-totalité
des médicaments qui obtiennent une à mm
sont admis au remboursement cette
situation est due au fait que le smr est
principalement appréciée en fonction de
l'efficacité et des effets indésirables
de médicaments c'est à dire de son
intérêt clinique
le critère d'admission remboursement
fondée sur l'intérêt de santé publique
c'est à dire l'intérêt pour la
collectivité impact du médicament sur
l'état de santé de la population réponse
apportée à un besoin de santé publique
et un pack du médicament sur le système
de santé pourtant prévu pour
l'appréciation du smr est peu utilisé en
pratique la prise en compte effective du
critère d'intérêt de santé publique
permettrait de donner une dimension
collective à l'appréciation du smr et à
l'admission au remboursement et irait
dans le sens d'une meilleure analyse
médico économique lorsque l'intérêt
qu'il présente pour la santé publique
n'est pas suffisant une prise en charge
par la collectivité serait alors
injustifiée
voilà l'amendement que madame archimbaud
et les sénatrices et sénateurs
écologistes sont présentés mais ayant
compris et ayant apprécié l'intervention
de madame la ministre j'ai compris qu'il
y avait besoin d'aller plus loin dans
cette appréciation et comme c'est un
amendement lourds qui va tout à fait
dans ce sens j'ai compris qu'il fallait
prendre le temps de la réflexion le
temps du test et donc je le retire je
remercie merci monsieur nécessaires cet
amendement et en retirer nous passons à
l'amendement numéro 60 2 présenté par le
rapporteur général au nom de commission
alors cet amendement monsieur le
président
dans un contexte pour objet donc dans un
contexte de mise sur le marché de
médicaments qui peut être justifiée des
prix élevés par l'importance de
l'innovation qu'ils apportent n'apparaît
que la prise en charge par la sécurité
sociale du traitement ne peut être
justifiée que si l'industriel apporte le
plus haut niveau de preuves
scientifiques c'est-à-dire des études
comparatives
lorsque le comparateur existe cette
mesure était prévue par la loi du 29
décembre 2011 relative au renforcement
de la sécurité sanitaire du médicament
et des produits de santé mais soumise à
un décret en conseil d'état qui n'est
pas paru à ce jour votre commission et
notre commission plus exactement vous
propose donc de rendre la mesure
d'application directe à l'heure actuelle
les services du ministère considère
qu'ils ne peuvent définir par décret les
cas où une stratégie thérapeutique
existent pour permettre la comparaison
nous semble que cette question doit être
réglée entre la haute autorité de santé
les industriels
mais trois ans après le vote de la loi
continuer ce qu'on a nous contenter
dc100 comparateur nous placent en
situation de faiblesse pour évaluer
correctement l'innovation en matière de
médicaments et donc je note d'ailleurs
que au royaume uni les clients
l'équivalent de la has a déjà adopté
cette manière de procéder aux
évaluations donc
notre commission propose
sept mesures d'application directe merci
monsieur important général quel est
l'avis du gouvernement
j'avais un avis défavorable monsieur le
président parce que effectivement nous
dans l'état actuel des choses le décret
qui permet l'application de la loi n'a
pas été pris pour des raisons de
faisabilité nous n'avons pas les essais
comparateur donc nous ne savons pas
faire donc on peut voter d'application
directe nous ne saurons pas faire et
donc les choses n'avanceront pas plus
vite moi je ne me perds pas en longues
explications jeudi nous ne savons pas
faire donc
avis défavorable maintenant je voudrais
juste faire une observation sur
l'amendement précédent qui a été adopté
nous verrons comment nous la procédure
parlementaire chemine mai et j'attire
juste l'attention sur le fait que le
directeur de la haute autorité de santé
agence indépendante assurément
le président de la haute autorité de
santé qui est une agence indépendante
bien sûr
considère utile de
promouvoir des amendements auprès de la
représentation nationale
ont indépendamment
des discussions qui ont lieu quant à la
faisabilité du dispositif tel qu'elle
est jugée par l'ensemble des autres
agences et du gouvernement et d'ailleurs
comme il fait donc preuve de beaucoup de
célérité en la matière je souhaite
qu'ils fassent preuve de beaucoup de
célérité sur d'autres sujets sur
lesquels nous attendons la haute
autorité de santé en particulier
l'évaluation des médicaments et la
proposition de protocole pour permettre
toute une série d'avancées du système de
santé mais je ne doute pas que la haute
autorité de santé saura faire preuve
d'autant de diligence sur ces sujets
importants pour les français que sur
celui là merci madame la ministre je
vais donc mettre aux voix l'amendement
62 avec un avis défavorable du
gouvernement je ne vois pas
d'explications de vote qui est pour cet
amendement
qui est contre
l'amendement est adopté
passons à l'amendement 63 monsieur le
rapporteur général vous avez toujours la
parole
oui merci monsieur le président
l'admission d'un produit de santé au
remboursement nécessite que soit évalué
la porte thérapeutique du produit mais
également son efficience au regard des
alternatives médicalement pertinente cet
amendement prévoit donc la commission
d'évaluation économique et de santé
publique qui selon décret du 2 octobre
2012 évalue les produits revendiquant un
progrès médical est susceptible d'avoir
un impact significatif sur les dépenses
d'assurance-maladie émettent un avis sur
le remboursement des médicaments en neuf
en effet l'analyse de leur efficience au
regard des stratégies en concurrence et
nature à éclairer la décision publique
en matière d'accès aux remboursements
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
vous proposons cet amendement merci
monsieur le rapporteur général à vis du
gouvernement
je sais pas
vous avez voté un amendement qui met en
place littéraire
donc je sais plus moi
je sais plus faire
donc soit on fait comme si y'avait pas
littéraire et puis on continue à
regarder les amendements ou vous mettez
en place des dispositifs qui n'ont de
sens que par rapport à l'ancien système
où votre logique c'est de retirer les
amendements qui ne correspondent plus au
système que vous avez appelez de vos
voeux dès le 1er janvier 2015 donc oui
non mais je ne dis pas qu'il ne fallait
pas élaboré c'est un moment je comprends
bien comment ils ont été élaborés mais
puisque le précédent a été adopté il n'y
a pas d'incompatibilité juridique mais
il ya juste une question formelle donc
moi je peux vous répondre que je trouve
pas le dispositif
adapté puisque il rencontre un certain
nombre d'oppositions je peux répondre à
votre amendement mais
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
vous avez défendu un système qui est
totalement
totalement différent
voilà
voilà pour le débat des sénateurs sur le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2015 il ne devrait
aborder l'un des points clés de ce
projet de loi à savoir la modulation des
allocations familiales que dans la
soirée rappelons que le sénat de droite
veut supprimer cette mesure voulue par
le gouvernement mesure qui le juge
contraire aux principes d'universalité
de ses prestations et là dessus
d'ailleurs soutenu par de nombreux
parlementaires de gauche aussi bien les
communistes que les écologistes ou
encore que certains socialistes comme
marie noëlle lienemann autre point sur
lequel le sénat va continuer à
intervenir eh bien il va continuer en
proposant un milliard d'économies
supplémentaires dans cette partie donc
consacré aux dépenses du budget de la
sécurité sociale en tout cas les
discussions vont se poursuivre avant se
poursuivre ce soir mais aussi demain est
certainement jusqu'à demain soir les
sénateurs vont donc continuer à plancher
sur ce budget vous pouvez toujours voir
et revoir toute la séance sur notre site
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité parlementaire à 19h pour 24
heures sénat présenté par jérôme rabier
très bonne fin de journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires
à